експерти міжнародного агентства з
Атомної енергії завершили свою першу
екскурсію гігантським ядерним об'єктом
на Запоріжжі за останні тижні окупована
Росією юзс зазнала кількох
потенційно-катастрофічних зборів багате
прагне розмістити там своїх постійних
представників незважаючи на небезпеку
ракетних ударів поблизу
ми нікуди не йдемо багате зараз на АЕС і
не йде звідти а збирається залишатися
Там ми маємо намір забезпечити тривалу
присутність на АЕС з кількома моїми
експертами і Звісно зараз у моєї команди
багато роботи щодо детального аналізу
деяких більш технічних аспектів того що
ми побачили
тим часом українська сторона розчарована
заявами грусі адже головною метою
українських та міжнародних зусиль є
демілітаризація ядерного об'єкту а
закликів до РФ вивести свою війська з
території зс так і не прозвучало
Коли нарешті з території запорізької АЕС
вийдуть російські військові коли Вони
заберуть свою зброю боєприпаси коли вони
припинять обстріли енергодару та
сусідніх районів та свої провокації
Запорізька станція зможе повернутись до
цілком безпечної роботи яка і була
завжди
під контролем України і головне що має
відбутись це демілітаризація території
станції саме це є метою українських і
міжнародних зусиль і погано що ми поки
що не почули відповідних закликів від
мегате Хоча і говорили про це з паном
моросі на нашій зустрічі в Києві Це був
ключовий
ключовий безпековий пункт наших
домовленостей це говорилося чітко
димілітаризація і повний контроль
українських атомників
українська сторона також оскаржує що
окупанти не пустили незалежних
журналістів на територію зс натомість
організували масовку своїх
пропагандистів і намагаються перетворити
місію мегатея на Запорізький АЕС на
безплідну екскурсію по станції схожі
застереження в інтерв'ю ДВ висловив
також один із колишніх працівників зс
Олег Коропець який до минулого тижня
коли він в останній був на зміні
працював інженером на АЕС чоловік не
вірить що місія міжнародного агентства з
Атомної енергії зможе вплинути на
ситуацію і сумнівається що мегате
отримала повну картину того що
відбувається на електростанції судячи з
того як організовувався візит знімальної
групи російського телебачення
на камеру что они да они вывозят техник
тобто вони показали на камери що вони
вивозять техніку що там Все нормально
Тільки телебачення поїхало вони назад
привезли
розумієте вони дуже гарно вони цього
навчилися у них Пропаганда Працює
відмінно вони навчилися показувати
картинку ось приїдемо Гете вони покажуть
картинку мегате поїде і все буде як
раніше нічого не зміниться нічого не
зміниться
Крупець також переживає що дедалі більше
його колег як і він залишають свою
роботу і що ризик ядерної катастрофи
зростає не лише через ймовірні обстріли
але й через брак персоналу
ремонти права дітей сейчас эти ремонты
потрібно щорічні ремонти проводити А
зараз ці ремонти не проводяться це
атомна станція Все повинно бути як
годинник тобто день година доба ремонт
початку ремонт кінця графіки я на кожен
день на кожну зміну це повинно бути як
годинник А зараз годинник поламався він
то тікає але він поламався
у національному науковому центрі
радіаційної медицини вважають що цей
аспект захист працівників зс і
забезпечення їм нормальних умов праці
теж має бути На порядку денному місії
мегате
вкрай Важливо щоб психологічний тиск на
працівників зс було послаблено адже вони
уже майже 6 місяців під дулами
російських військ що аж ніяк не сприяє
безпеці
тим часом у Європі зростають
занепокоєння щодо ризику нової атомної
Катастрофи на континенті наслідки якої
можуть бути навіть гіршими за Чорнобиль
не дуже доречно порівнювати наслідки
Чорнобиля з можливими наслідками аварії
на зс по-перше це різні типи реакторів а
також різні причини у будь-якому випадку
ризик аварії на зс дуже високий наслідки
такої аварії можна буде радше порівняти
з фокусімою а не Чорнобилем але за
найгіршого сценарію наслідки аварії на
зс можуть бути гіршими ніж Чорнобилі
фокусіма разом адже Там йшлося про один
або два реактори у випадку Запоріжжя це
аж шість реакторів і відповідно більші
обсяги атомного палива якщо постраждають
всі реактори наслідки будуть
катастрофічними для всієї Європи не лише
для України
тим часом мешканці енергодара масово
тікають з міста деякі з цих людей
провели години а деякі дні в очікуванні
цього моменту хтось тікав від боїв хтось
від життя в окупації а хтось і відновує
ядерної загрози
в зону
радіаційну ну неофіційно Ми там тоже там
стріляють до нас чуть вистріли дуже чуть
Ну зірвалися зібрали вещи зірвалися я ж
кажу їдемо Ну у Запоріжжі біженці
реєструються отримують їжу та допомогу
автобуси чекають на тих хто хоче їхати
далі за останні кілька днів багато хто
прибув з енергодара який постраждав від
обстрілів
Ми поговорили з кількома людьми які
щойно покинули Енергодар та атомну
електростанцію вони говорять про
постійні обстріли вони кажуть що бояться
того що може статися з атомною
електростанцією і що вони хочуть поїхати
звідси якнайдалі
жоден з них не погодився говорити на
камеру побоюючись за родичів які
залишилися на окупованих територіях
ніхто не знає як довго цей шлях втечі з
російською окупації що буде відкритий